wir werden tripp in der höhle
veranstalten abgeschafft
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen heute zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal zusammen mit hier
sind es bereits hier zwischen und so
haben wir mal wieder das glücksrad aus
dem keller ausgekramt allerdings werden
jetzt häufig so machen das dann
beispielsweise draufsteht lag ist die
klobrille ab in rio oder so muss sondern
es geht um dinge die wir in minecraft
heute zusammen machen werden das heutige
video ist eine neue folge minecraft
freiwillig dass wir beispielsweise
sachen drauf stehen wie beispielsweise
hält hier auf den gegenüber liegenden
dinge an der zeit wenn wir das treffen
dann müssen wir uns einen fällen
baugemeinschaft weil wir noch kein
richtiges essen haben
hier ist ressourcen da sein gehalt beim
bootfahren inseln ein paar andere sachen
rock sind dass ich jetzt sagen mit
drehenden sie erstmal und wir haben eine
aufgabe was er als erstes und der
heutigen folge mein fall
machen würden
[Musik]
das ist manchmal wieder und wir machen
das jetzt einfällt hey hallo wie geht's
dir schräg
mir geht autor und herzlich willkommen
jetzt hier in minecraft bei der lieben
freunde der schule
was läuft da nicht dadurch finde ich
einen blog abbauen so jule um uns
einfällt zu machen brauchen wir als
erste rein gras bzw wir brauchen nicht
gras sondern wir brauchen die samen die
das gras und es gibt einfach mal gras
kaputt nötig hat das gras nicht kaputt
das geht einfach nicht kaputt so ich
habe jetzt neun samen uns gegönnt
das heißt wir müssen jetzt einfällt
anbauen dafür brauchen wir doch noch mal
hin auf java was sind deine sachen die
andere
[Musik]
wo ist mein holz gut mein erde
wo sind meine stärken meine unterhose
auch nochmal mit helfen wir unseren
fällt ja wenn dein auto das irgendwie an
ernten oder sorgfältig ja schön schön
unser tolles bild haben wir jetzt fertig
gebaut werden fordert dass als nächstes
für die nächste sache die wir mal etwas
machen werden wenn ich jetzt mal das
glücksrad sehen und gesehen oder
flüstert landet jetzt meine die spannung
steigt
wir werden trip in der höhle
veranstalten
jetzt fängt es an zu wissen ja was
machen wir denn jetzt warten ist vorbei
weil wir müssen in der höhle dann auf
eine höhle
wir haben es jetzt hier so ein paar
sachen getrachtet für die höhle das
heißt er ich würde sagen jetzt los frage
ist nur wo wir eine höhle finden zwei
vollidioten auf der suche nach einer
höhle drei wochen später
ich weiß nicht wo wir hinwollen
ich habe halt echt noch so eine kacke
internet wird sagen höhle wollen wir das
verschieben der leute seid uns bitte
nicht böse ich würde gerne in der höhle
gehen jetzt und es kann auch beim
glücksrad raus dass wir das machen
sollen aber die sache ist halt einfach
wir sehen halt nichts
bei diesem regen hier ich die da hinten
ist eine spinne und wir sind halt auch
viel zu schlecht ausgestattet
ich bin ja dass eine spinne also ich
würde sagen wir drehen jetzt wieder das
glücksrad und guck mal was wir als
nächstes machen müssen
das war nochmal hin will
wir haben uns einfach gedacht dass wir
die andere seite der insel noch erkunden
also wir kennen ja bisher die nördliche
südliche und östliche seite der insel
aber am besten gar nicht mehr westküste
ja genau das heißt wir gehen jetzt mal
zur west coast drüber und ok also ihr
seht doch schon das wetter ist auch da
hinten sind noch die zombies die gerade
beim regen gekommen sind wir haben also
gezogen dass wir die insel erkunden
sollen
wir kennen ja schon diese seite von der
insel hinten ist ja nur wasser wir waren
schon dahin da hinten ist nämlich auch
nur was soll man schon dahinter das auch
nur wasser jetzt jude aber wir waren
noch nicht dort das heißt da werden wir
jetzt mal zusammen hin laufen also noch
mal kurz die orientierung da vorne ist
unser hause waren schon dort überall und
gehen jetzt mal in diese richtung
juli haben tiere was wo loddar über
kleine pilze sind und wissen wohin gott
es ist auf jeden fall megane als dass
wir hier auch so vernünftige tiere haben
vernünftiges holz und auch alle spinnen
schulz ja diesen hund dessen hund ich
bin ganz ehrlich eigentlich dass sie
ziemlich cool aus als er ist ein kleiner
hase ja mir coole verschiedene bäume wir
haben tiere und so weiter und so fort
aber ich weiß nicht von wo viel gekommen
sind also da hinten ist jule die richtig
wertvoll viele hatten übrigens
aufgeschrieben dass wir jetzt wirklich
eine zweite kämen hierfür jude aufbauen
sollen die sache ist dass wir nicht
gedacht hätten dass so viele von euch
das wirklich wollen mich zu sehen dass
so viele von euch wirklich juli sehen
wollen also am ende das wirklich wollt
dann kaufe ich noch eine zweite kamera
da stellen wir die hierhin aber wenn ihr
sagt sony muss unbedingt aber ich halte
mich jetzt weiterkommen ist schon lustig
oder schreibt sie und die kommentare
wir müssen uns merken dass da hinten
unsere bude steht und wir gehen jetzt
einfach nur in die richtung weiter
also nehme ich mir noch die süße beeren
mit und wir konnten jetzt mal die insel
so ein bisschen weiter in die richtung
ist auf jeden fall mega gegenüber also
hunde haben also wölfe ja noch wir haben
hier
schweinchen wir haben kühe wir haben
hier guck mal wie eine höhle egal warum
regnet das denn jetzt schon wieder es
hat gerade aufgehört es hängt wieder
aber da war es aber juli kommt hier
vorne lang
hier ist eine höhle also da könnten
jetzt kommt wir haben ja gerade gezogen
wir können kleinen blick auf jeden fall
in die hülle reinwerfen wieder raus
ich hab's geschafft
danke dass du so ich hab dich gar nicht
gesehen juni wo bist du denn was auf
jeden fall in pfeile hinter dem ellbogen
stecken also gehen wir noch ein
stückchen weiter hier in die höhle rein
ich glaube die ist nicht allzu groß ist
sieht man auch schon hier ist was man
kennt wirklich meine mitarbeiter ich hab
doch gesagt du dich darauf gehen war die
jetzt hier einfach mit so einem
wasserfall gegen die runterkommen du
bist genau in so eine schlucht
reingefallen ich versuche deine sachen
zu retten ist ich kann aber nicht
versprechen dass ich hier nicht auch
sterben werden abgeschafft
doch wir müssen uns jetzt beeilen und
die scheiß sachen wieder kriegen also
das war jetzt auch nicht so krasse
sachen aber es war halt das einzige was
wir hatten also hier war auf jeden fall
die höhle die wir eingegangen sind das
heißt ich laufe jetzt mal so ein
bisschen hier lang das hinter mir sind
hier um die ecke rum dann sind wir hier
lang und in die andere höhle rein und
hier gegen das wasser runter ok also
unsere sachen sind auf jeden fall noch
da ich weiß nicht ob wir noch die zombie
so gar keine ahnung was ich vermisse ich
ein paar sekunden später
es gab ziemlich hier immer da und ist
eine hexe juli vergiftet und geweckt
nein
[Musik]
sind wir so beschissen also tech3 wieder
hier in der höhle angekommen wieder hier
vorne durch und hier in das loch rhein
wo sind die verdammten sachen von unten
ist ja juli vorhin gestorben aber hier
liegen auch keine richtigen sachen also
keine fackeln et cetera
[Musik]
wo bin ich denn eigentlich gestorben ich
glaube ich bin irgendwie hier lang
gelaufen und dann war ich ja okay hier
ist meine sache okay bitte hier sind
keine skelette weg ins kleine dreckigen
ja gut wir auf jeden fall eine super
insel erkundungstour
ja da kommt die jüngste aus der höhle
rausgelaufen das heißt wir gehen jetzt
hier rechts hoch und schauen mal uns
noch ein bisschen weiter die insel hier
ankommen dass hier das ist mir das ist
nicht die höhle in der weiteren waren
okay anscheinend ist unsere insel doch
nicht so langweilig leute wie sie jetzt
mal wieder zu hause angekommen es fängt
wieder an zu pisten alter scheiß werte
auf dieser insel das denn wahr sein wo
sind wir denn hier alter nordsee oder
war auf jeden fall wenn wir an der
stelle das heutige minecraft wie die
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben freunde
wenn es einfach gedacht hey bevor wir
jetzt einfach eine sache machen scheint
lassen wir das glücksrad entscheiden was
wir machen und wer uns jetzt ein feld
gebaut wir haben ein bisschen die insel
erkundet und die schlussendlich waren
wir doch noch in einer höhle tatsächlich
jetzt am ende wenn sich der zweite teil
minecraft mit julia und luca gefallen
hat dann das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video ihr da schreibt uns
gerne in die kommentare was wir der
nächsten folge machen sollen und falls
sie noch kein abonnent von meinem kanal
seit dann klickt er noch abonnieren das
ist kostenlos und verpasst keine videos
mehr und was ihr das ganze video bereits
über ja schon gesehen habt es dass ich
einen schwarzen diana habe und zwar ein
handy mit einem frottee schriftzug luke
ruderer auf der hude kommt am 09
den lukas 18 15 und dann gibt es auch in
weiß also hier genau der gleiche auch in
weiß und es kommt auch noch ein buntes
smiley kissen zwar erstmal in den shop
es wird von diesem rudi 500 stück geben
jetzt wird von dem weissenhof die 500
stück geben und es wird von dem kissen
auch nur 1000 stück geben also alles
sehr stark limitiert das wird zu den
ersten 1000 bestellungen eine von mir
signierte autogrammkarte geben also ja
ich will mich sehr freuen wenn ihr am 09
dupont de vorbeischauen werdet und jetzt
kommt das auto
[Musik]